here's an awesome question from South
Africa you need to figure out the area
of ABCD which is made up of two
triangles ABD and BDC angle a is the
right angle ABD is 35 degrees BCD is 45
degrees and BDC is 10 degrees with a B
equaling 20 centimeters
so to work it out figure out the
remaining angles CBD is 125 degrees and
ADB is 55 degrees now we are going to
flip the triangle BCD
now since 55 plus 125 is equal to 180
ADC Prime is a straight line segment so
we've created a right triangle where one
angle is 45 degrees and the other angle
is also 45 degrees therefore both sides
are equal to each other and AC Prime is
equal to 20 centimeters so the area is
20 times 20 all over 2 which equals 200
square centimeters amazing